today we're going to be reacting to our
brother Andrew on his new show on Rumble
so we got this there's the point where
I'm gonna let loose
in court on transcripts I was called a
misogynist like because I said I said in
my song I said I said um name a rapper
with who doesn't have a lyric that can
be called misogynistic name any rapper
yeah no yeah any rapper of the world who
doesn't but that's what's happened with
these labels now they've thrown them
around so wildly yeah I just think every
man who's half a man I think a woman
like to respect to be honest it's all
hurray
Muslim I'm Muslim yeah okay he is
no but you were having
a steam room yeah he loves that and they
both had girlfriends oh boy no wait wait
no wait no wait no wait all right
Jennifer let's wait that Dubai is
perfectly leveraged I think that since
I've been here I've been meeting with
very influential and important people
things people who know things about
things and everybody seems to understand
the device perfectly placed not only
geographically but politically to be
between the two great Rising powers of
Earth I think that divides a safe bet
for all of humanity for the future I
also love it here I love the strong
faith of the place I love how safe it is
it's really a great City and truthfully
I don't think it has any competition
globally so we're in one of the best
places on Earth to be it's funny when I
when we come to Dubai there's always
some American who goes bro the Middle
East is it okay over there like my
friend you're in Detroit
what the hell are you talking about it's
fine no further questions your honor I
think he's Muslim for sure it's fun to
love bro the smile on his face like you
could see that how proud he was the
smile on his face when he's like I'm
Muslim yeah
and six nine asked him that no
hesitation no uh I consider it not I am
Muslim yeah what about it bro it's crazy
it's crazy what Iman does to a person
I'm not talking about Andrew I'm talking
about me man before with Andrew Tate I
never hated the guy but I was like man
like well you know what's up with this
guy in some cases
ever since he accepted Islam bro I have
love for him I swear to God I have love
for him as my brother in Islam like I
can't even control it it's subhanallah
it's like that's that's how beautiful
Islam is so I'm very happy for the guy
man I'm proud and a little sub note
I don't think this is really the purpose
of this reaction but I wanna I wanna
mention something he's he's really smart
Allah Mubarak when it comes to politics
when it comes I'm not saying he's a
politician or anything or he's like
brilliant with it but even the fact that
he mentioned Dubai's in a good location
and it's safe he's absolutely right
geographically because if things go to
heck and and people start going to war
there are certain places in the world
that are safer than others obviously the
West is not going to be safe
uh Russia and John are probably going to
be you know in the middle of War
recruiting people I think Dubai is a
safe bet
in the Middle East as well 100 there's
that old saying bro like in Dubai you
can have a Lamborghini and leave the
keys in the in the car when it's just
parked and it's on and No One's Gonna
touch it bro yeah yes I mean they have
their problems obviously you know they
are westernized but in terms of location
and and and some of the cultures and
stuff yeah alhamdulillah a lot better
subhanallah I don't know what do you
think oh yeah no no no no I talk too
much I talk too much forgive me no I
generally want to know I know bro
because there's no more questions after
this one bro because we've been
responding to his tweets or you know
posts that he's made now it's like bro
he said it there's
No Doubt
I mean man
I just wished that same you know
uh may go up or make that Allah just
makes it easy for him to get closer to
him
and that he learns more and that he uh
he keeps that peace and has that peace
that I talked about I was asked about
this in my life today on Instagram first
time I ever did a live on Instagram by
the way I thought I should uh throw that
out there but
um I was asked about Andrew Taylor and I
was like you know what
so if all I got in then you know my love
listening and may Allah continue to
guide him and Elevate him in this life
and uh just allow him to do the best in
this world you know like yeah bro he has
he's in a position where he can help out
a lot he can do a lot for a lot of
people in need in this world so
uh may he be able to see that as well I
mean I mean I want to rewind it a little
bit to uh to uh the clip where six nine
asked him and I want you guys to hear
what Tristan's Tristan Tate said
he is
he is but I'm not so Andrew's listening
to all this all this nonsense all this
crap all this degeneracy from six nine
and he's like bro this is all Haram are
you Muslim yes I'm Muslim and then
Tristan says he is but I'm not Christian
bro we know you're next you got this
yeah
bro the Snickers next time
see me and sneago I'm pretty sure all of
us are mutuals with him on Instagram so
I saw this story he he storied uh the
Andrew Tate uh praying and he was like w
you know like he knows bro he knows he
knows we're coming from next bro
bro
and you guys want to know the craziest
thing
before remember how I was saying like oh
you know Muhammad hijab you know
probably just spoke to him
and then he accepted this them that they
didn't even have that conversation yet
also it's actually a live stream uh I
don't know if it's gonna be live but
they didn't record it yet so he accepted
Islam before even speaking to Mohamed
oh my God bro so now that that live
stream is going to be amazing because
now we can talk about his revert story
he could talk about Abram to Islam you
could talk about some of the setbacks
subhanallah bro I think it's going to be
a good inshallah bro I was literally
talking to Mohammed last week and I was
like bro you should get on her on her
Channel again he's like let's wait till
after the Andrew Tate podcast so then
we'll have more to talk about I was like
okay
but no I didn't even know that he it's
like not filmed it you know because
usually with Muhammad hijab Jordan
Peterson bro things are filmed months
and you know prior weeks prior and then
they edit it later you know to come and
then they drop it but I saw some Channel
bro post uh one of the screenshots with
mohammedab and Andrew Tate it was like
some poster and it was like this will be
a live stream by Sunday
so if that's true I don't know what it's
going to be but if it's a live stream
that means bro it's not even filmed yet
so for sure it's going to be after he's
Muslim and they can actually talk as
brothers in Islam like take that in bro
because before I thought it was going to
be Muhammad with Andrew Tate trying to
give dawa or China you know what I mean
yeah yeah
subhanallah it's gonna be good man it's
gonna be good I think Insha'Allah
this I think it's a huge W I don't want
to say for Islam but for for people for
men especially because having someone
that influential coming to Islam
obviously is going to bring more people
to Islam or at least put more eyes on
Islam and people will be like wow if
someone like Andrew takes accepted Islam
you know maybe there is something there
and then they'll look into it and I I
agree 100 with what you guys were saying
before about Tristan table Hamza
we invite all of you to Islam and if you
guys aren't ready to accept we invite
all you to come discuss on camera off
camera you know in person whatever you
guys want sha Allah we're down
let's just hit us up Insha'Allah we
invite you guys
imagine how crazy that would be and you
take
his brother Tristan
sneaker
bro you have all these people
reverting to Islam bro like listen these
people have a lot of mutual followers a
lot of people who like watch all of them
you know because they all kind of talk
about self-improvement or just being
better as a man in general right
bro like imagine all these people were
watching like all these different
channels all these different people and
they just started seeing like left and
right these people converting to Islam
right oh they're bro they're in touch
with rappers celebrity even six nine
brothers six nine asked are you Muslim
like he knew what that meant yeah I
don't know but like I wanted to share
something with that uh about what Romney
Said So Daniel hakikachu right he put
this on his uh on a YouTube Community
post yesterday or it was earlier today
right he said a comment on a recent live
stream there are countless people around
the world who greatly respect Islam but
are on the edge of converting they just
need a little nudge Andrew tape becoming
Muslim has provided many with that nudge
that they needed it's an absolute win
alhamdulillah so one of the screenshots
that he posted was from his life someone
wrote I'm a Christian but converted to
Islam yesterday when I heard the good
news about Andrew take converting to
Islam let's look at the good side of
this and keep praying Allah guides and
leads him right because I know that
there are more white males like me that
will join Islam in the coming weeks
because Andrew Tate just did and it's
not to say that you know it's only
because of Andrew Tate or anything weird
or Shirkey like that but it's like bro
these people are already kind of edging
they have was was intrusive thoughts
doubts they have misconceptions they
have things that are kind of setting
them off but they're just like yo Andrew
Tate did it the most narcissistic
misogynistic painted man who is so
arrogant but he's putting his hat on the
floor for Allah he's putting his head on
the mat meaning he's putting Allah over
him there must be something with this
you know bro it's like I've been saying
since the beginning
like he's just playing a character
almost all these people who are like at
the top of the top like I'm talking
about like the controversial they say
things and you're like yo like did this
guy really say this and they're getting
all this attention bro it's it's an act
and I'm not even trying to downplay it
because it it did exactly what he was
intending for it to do right but he
played this act and people painted this
picture of who he was bro but like man
like a lot of times you could hear him
speaking and you could see like okay
yeah like he's putting on this like this
mask as like this is okay this is
but in reality like he's actually pretty
humble dude he's actually like
pretty down to earth and everything and
I've been saying this since day one bro
um
that is true 100 and I've I've seen
small Clips here and there especially
recently there was I think the guy that
was on the podcast beside between Andrew
Tate and six nine I think he said no
pardon me his name is Steve from he's
from the part of the mouth boys oh yeah
they're not boys wow man that's crazy
that takes me way back Bro Saleem hey
bro bro all these born Muslims what you
doing insha Allah
talk to them one by one inshallah but uh
the point I wanted to make is even he
was saying like you know
he oh I remember the clip he gave them
both like Rolexes he's like you guys
have been so hospitable you guys are so
nice to me off camera you're always just
smiling and nice and that got me
thinking I'm like subhanallah you know
maybe on Hill is right but
um a big a big point I want to make and
this is for the viewers the people uh
the Muslims
sometimes Allah
uses people to bring other people to
Islam and I don't just mean that is in
Muslims I mean people who are unislamic
you know people who are are not Muslim
coming to Islam for example um
let me just set the the context right
now the Muslims are very small in number
Islam has only been around for about six
years the elites are still basically
pushing Auto worship and all this stuff
and and the Injustice and mistreatment
of the poor and the women and all that
stuff
so they used one uh they use I think
Donald uh Doral Akram I think is one
place basically that has a house of a
person as a hobby a companion of the
Prophet they were using that as kind of
their Masjid the place to pray now he
basically gave his whole house to that
so the Muslims would gather there and so
on and so forth
um
he's like listen we've dealt with this
guy Muhammad peace be upon him for so
long let's just get rid of him I'm done
I'm not wasting my time I'm gonna kill
him and we're gonna be done with all of
this
he goes to that place the house to kill
the prophet peace be upon him and one
sahabi who's Muslim but he didn't come
out publicly he went to Omar he's like
he saw he's angry heading that direction
he's like that can't be good it's like
what are you doing he's like I'm gonna
go kill Muhammad put an end to it this
is how open he was I'm gonna go kill him
put an end to it he was a big guy Omar
he's a big scary guy they was they were
they would say if he's in a crowd he
would look like he's on a camel imagine
that subhanallah so he's going to kill
the prophet peace and blessings to be
upon him and then the sahabi stops him
he's like you have a problem with Islam
you know before you kill the prophet
shouldn't you go to you know your own
family your own house and see what
they're doing because the sister and her
husband so his brother-in-law accepted
Islam so he's like what the heck are you
talking about you know he got angry he
went to the house he started banging on
the door and then the altercation kind
of broke out he ended up hitting his
sister and he saw what he did in that
moment and he's had a realization like
what the heck is wrong what am I doing
yeah yeah so he's like
let me see the Quran they had a little
manuscript a little bit of Quran they're
reading he's like let me see it
and he's like his sister looked at me
she's like you're dirty you can't touch
it go take a shower go clean yourself
and come back and you can read it so he
did that he came back he read it
he left he went to the process at him he
went back to the process at him and
passed the son and in the Gathering he
ran up to Omar and he grabbed him he
grabbed him he's like what are you doing
here
and he said I came to accept Islam
up until that point the Muslims were
hiding in a house unable to pray in
front of the Kappa that's right down the
street because every time they would go
and pray they would get beat up
but now the Omar became a Muslim there
were two lines that were formed one led
by Hamza a big guy the uncle the prophet
one led by Omar they the stat second
they walked right to the Kaaba they they
all prayed they all prayed in Salah
and nobody could touch them because Omar
was now a Muslim
and then we see when tribes leaders
became Muslim the whole tribe became
Muslim when the prophet salaam he
entered Madina as the ruler and they and
then they conquested Mecca once they
conquered Mecca other people became
Muslim they were waiting for the
conquest of Mecca to happen subhanallah
so these things
are important for people to accept Islam
and we should see Andrew Tain in that
same exact light why would it be any
different oh 100 100
those eye-opening
really goes to show all these
accusations bro like there's more to a
person than you think you know back then
when all this stuff was going on with
the trafficking and all that right there
was never any legitimate solid proof
that I've seen and again I could be
ignorant there could be solid proof he
could have done these things but I'm
saying there was never any proof so
there were countless women on Tick Tock
and Twitter anytime they would paint
fake stories or anything like that right
there was no proof of anything people
would comment Queen yes speak louder all
this you know but what I what I found
interesting was I found a bunch of women
that were literally posting videos and
talking about stories with their actual
face they had hundreds and thousands of
followers so they were real women right
and they basically said he was my
experience with Andrew Tate
he was my actual behind the scenes
experience oh I I think I've seen that
yeah yeah there were so many bro and any
time a woman made this it was like they
had millions of followers they were like
real people right you'd see other women
shaming them in the comments being like
what are you doing you're a pick me
you're desperate you're this you're
you're brainwashed you're look good to
see the grips Andrew Tate has on you
blink if you need help like bro what
make the truth come out and you know
Rectify those that have been oppressed
all the Injustice and inshallah we look
forward to Andrew Tate's growth as
awesome
I mean
and that being said